[Music]
visit our
[Music]
[Music]
- true to mention regrets
I had a few
[Music]
[Music]
you
so what is a man what has he got if not
himself then he has naught what does
that mean if you're walking around
trying to be more you suck at ball balls
but with your little went to head on the
tattoo to be accepted you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you might as well shoot yourself
in the head today [ __ ] but
besides that it's a beautiful day to be
alive
the birds are up the clouds [ __ ] god
the sun shining I got the best weed and
[ __ ] North America I got an easy day
today I got a podcast tonight who's
better than flopping you I'm sniffing a
hundred and fifty [ __ ] piss earlier I
just smoked a fart from [ __ ] Colorado
now jack
anyway what's out there you bad
[ __ ] uncle Joey hey drop us
some net Wednesday [ __ ] knowledge I'm
Adam but bling said listen my anthem has
always been
my way bison are okay but back I'll
raise my some hard-hitting guineas our
[ __ ] hobo get that moves a lot Burgin
and because of that they put this
[ __ ] savage medallion mining
understand me
what is a man what has he got if not
himself then he is not mr. Esmond to say
the things he truly feels not you know
the word of warning reveals what is that
[ __ ] tell me okay to say the things
he truly feels what 60% of America
cannot [ __ ] do because they are
worried about what the neighbor might
think me my friend I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] if the time your mind
you gotta say it and if it's what you
feel you gotta say them I move to
[ __ ] cube and you're getting on a
circle or pendant and I love those
t-shirts to you [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's all coming at you today right the
big black Kahuna I wish you would have
thought me just a little sooner anyway
we got some tremendous wave for today
killing [ __ ] understand you could see
the smoke when they just lay on the sand
the [ __ ] Road but they got hit by a
car what the [ __ ] yes it is it is Lee's
birthday today
he's like 24 him too
and means we only go deep in the murky
waters underworld
of a site that you know mate
the doorman isn't it popped up a with my
maid [ __ ] family members to get
the day off for the right [ __ ] foot
okay you might had a [ __ ] up morning
but uncle Joey's here never fear to
[ __ ] find out the SPD thoughts Marlo
all these bad [ __ ] allergies you want
better throughout the day with his
[ __ ] [ __ ]
take your [ __ ] black magic of
SmackDown sucker
nice
I feel the walked around my [ __ ]
eyeball sugar-snap and if you are
feeling the walked around your eye gloss
it's time to switch peepers just by the
time you smoked these bowls you should
be hearing [ __ ] noises Chinese people
singing
maybe I hear Chinese people shagging a
piece of the bone that's good
there's the ship they came but I'll be
understanding this yeah
look what's this in oh I have another
batch of that [ __ ] wedding cake
[Applause]
[Music]
a [ __ ] think it dealing with some
[ __ ] novice in will going deep in the
murky waters of the world without me
then when I see Lian ain't gonna even
[ __ ] it deeper again
listen you know
you know
I'm just the [ __ ] felon and trying to
push my back together again
and this is what helps me I don't need
to go to therapy L&T no [ __ ] hugs I
don't need no [ __ ] at all i dont need
dick
reflow is the [ __ ] ads okay
most MMA fighters have like a backing
makeup probably tied back when I talk
from a refill [ __ ] background
ah truly tremendous history that matters
there's nothing about this time in your
day ever stab his [ __ ]
in Tobruk
to figure out how to solve the problems
of the world this day is very important
these morning sessions with us as a
family they're very important to us
understand me
so I need this from you guys and he feel
allowed at this one we smoked down and
we see what's really cracked you
laughing you know what matters right now
what the [ __ ] it don't matter Joey Diaz
is knowing now what who gets a [ __ ]
about birth and gives a [ __ ] I want it
to be what the [ __ ] your dog this is the
I world gotta suckers go on and be a bad
[ __ ]
tell the guy walking on coals to take
that cold shove it up his ass he
understand me and kill those boys he's
missing on his ass for too long
[ __ ] make me and you were out
there slinging thick smoke and people
taking people to the next [ __ ]
level you follow me
that's why not boy am i [ __ ] anyway
I'd be around all day you want to
chitchat or whatever whatever sent me a
twit I don't know if I'm being Twitter
but I'll be [ __ ] around
yeah like rocking away a yo Adrian same
[ __ ] boy give me a yell and I'm here
with you smoking reefer philosophizing
making sure it is alright
he's better than you [ __ ] ever
Hey
you got Jesus in your back and a big
thing of funny go out there and shot
some [ __ ] shoot some [ __ ] do to
juice in their faces and let him know
who's [ __ ] runnin things all right and
they got a problem with that
come on your uncle Joey sent you I don't
[ __ ] lookin dog damn day okay man okay
is okay I love you guys stay black and
have a great day god bless you
or it that you think of my my than a big
bow and sukhoi his mama make do without
it but it's all about today [ __ ]
stay black I'll see you tonight on the
church